[Music]
Citroen designers don't care about what
other people think cars should look like
they have the confidence they can build
cars that are beautiful elegant
practical and comfortable and in 1955
this was the result the Citroen DS in
the world in 55 this was the very
beginning of the space race so when this
car was unveiled at the Paris Auto Show
it really caught people's attentions
partly because it looks like a spaceship
especially compared to everything else
that was on the road around then and
some of the technology that has onboard
is still more cutting-edge than we see
in cars today for what some call the
ultimate vintage car the DS was awfully
advanced the headlights swivel to
highlight the road
it came with hydropneumatic suspension a
revolution replacing mechanical springs
with a pressurized fluid for a super
smooth ride on France's pothole pact
post-war roads and it still works on
America's rough roads today so it's the
strange semi automatic gearbox that you
have to get used to you and that's just
the thing with Citron's they're
unforgiving if you don't know what
you're doing so you really have to learn
how to drive these cars they are not
something you can just jump into now one
of the cool features of this suspension
was I mean this car didn't come with a
jack if you've got a flat tire you just
pump it up as high as you can like it is
right now and then put a pole that it
came with underneath and then just lower
the suspension down again and the wheel
where you'd left the pole would stay
with that side of the car propped up in
the air you could just swap the we allow
put your spare on and be ready to go the
name in French
citrons home country is pronounced des s
which means goddess the D s was built
from 1955 to 1975 but it never sold very
well in the US it was designed for an
austere European market that
haxed big wasteful engines in 1970
Citroen launched the SM it was much more
of a driver's car with a proper v6
designed by Maserati which Citroen
briefly owned and what makes that so
special is that this car was released 15
years after the D s things haven't
really changed technology wise it still
uses that same hydropneumatic suspension
the same little mushroom button on the
floor for the braking and yet it still
feels revolutionary you can see the same
design influences the aerodynamic shape
the swiveling headlights the
all-encompassing hydraulic system but of
course the world had moved on from the
mid 50s the SM came just after Conchords
first flight a joint French British
project and another vision of the future
which seems to have influenced Citron's
designers these cars are part of a new
Citroen exhibition at the Mullen
automotive museum north of Los Angeles
46 of them in total will showcase the
brand through the years today the French
manufacturer is going on a hundred years
old
and is part of the huge PSA Peugeot
Citroen Group it has had to get a bit
more mainstream to survive but its
designers still love a bit of Gallic
quirk using the European auto shows to
demonstrate some truly original ideas
and also just a hint of that original DS
charm
[Music]